so you have made a project that has won
the Academy Award is the best feature
you it made a lot of money it was a
worldwide success maybe more important
you know we always talked about this you
know they'll animator saying your scenes
are there forever you've made a project
that people love and they're going to
love for many years to come and look at
so together as a team and with your
colleagues you've done this wonderful
achievement but the last thing I'd like
to ask you tonight is you know for you
personally what will you take away from
this experience that you thought was the
most impactful an important thing and
let's start with Jack at that say that's
a tough question because it really
depends on what what aspect of the
production you look at because you know
these guys were on much longer than I
was but I was on the film for two years
and and thinking back to my first few
days on the show there's a different
reward to that as there is to watching
an audience watch these films and so I
think there's there's an artistic
satisfaction that you get to have when
you see someone happen you know cry or
laugh or you know hearing an audience
laughs it's something you animated is a
particular joy but for me as a
first-time head of animation I think the
thing that I take away from this
experience is is that that maturation
and that growth of being a leader and
helping other people grow in order to
help create something like this I think
that's one of the most important things
that that these guys gave me the
opportunity to do on this film that will
really change how i approach films going
forward okay for me one of the things
that you know I'm very focused on the
visuals is it's really the power of
collaboration we talked about it quite a
few times tonight I think I always have
a vision early on of what film could
look like and this film was such a
revelation for me because I think with
everybody's addition all the way from
the developers through every person that
worked on every asset and then put them
together into shots this film came out
looking far better than I ever thought
it would
and that would not have been possible by
an individual or even by a small team it
took every input of all these hundreds
of people to make something that could
have these incredibly intense visuals
that again were so much better than I
ever imagined they would be you know
yeah for me the collaboration is also
huge for me kind of more from a just
kind of emotional energizing point and
everything I learned from it I feel like
I learned so much every day from
everybody and also for me like for a
movie like this it's just like you know
how many movies do you go to work on
where you get to do a flyover City you
get this emotional moment with a mule
hero watching his brother on this video
and it just it makes you cry and then
you go to somewhere like the wormhole
the owner is just just not you know I
feel so lucky to have that kind of
opportunity to do that kind of range of
lighting and it's just amazing yeah for
me I'll just say that this has been a
great experience this night being able
to come here and see you guys again
because we're all off working on
different movies now and to watch these
clips we're now a few months removed
from the release of the film and so it's
nice to see the clips again in this
amazing screen and get the band back
together one more time and the thing
that strikes me as I was watching the
presentation is I didn't understand all
of it alright let's do it again guys can
you come back he'll doesn't actually
bought a lot of it is we've done our job
yeah and and so but it just shines a
light for for me on the fact that on how
reliant we are on each other and how
deeply collaborative it is there's
really not one person that can explain
the entire process of how to make an
animated movie from beginning to end
that person doesn't exist it's
impossible and and and really it isn't
it isn't a handful of people that makes
these movies it's hundreds of people and
the idea that hundreds of artists and
managers will work for years on one
piece of art is an incredible idea to me
and and the fact that I'm turned out at
all is a miracle and and so I'm really
proud of the movie that we all made
together and and and this kind of
environment this call you keep hearing
collaborative kind of environment is
what I want to work in for the rest of
my career and so yeah that's that's what
I I take is just how much I enjoyed
working with these guys and I would and
I look forward to working with all of
them again yeah I mean to me you know
everybody in the credits did something
that saved the day at one point or
another over the course of making this
film and and their contributions were
absolutely critical to how it turned out
and so you know on that level I'm so
proud of just the collected you know the
thing that we did that we all did
together on a personal level you know I
it started with passion for Marvel and
for Disney and and you know I think when
I look back on the film now and watch it
there are moments in this where that
little kid and the Hulk jammies would go
out of his mind watching this film and
so on a personal level I I feel like I
achieved you know what what I set out to
do at the beginning which is to somehow
fulfill that that passion that I had for
these two things so on a professional
level and a personal level I couldn't be
more happy with how this turned out
and for me it was seeing Donna and his
hulk Jamie I don't want to see that yeah
now you know it's um it's funny I was
very lucky to produce a film called
tangled four years ago it's not an
applause line and I thought I had done
my do you know I worked with this
incredible team and kind of reinvented
the fairy tale to a degree and then you
work with these bums and they're great
they're great and I learned to just keep
telling stories